the promotional campaign for x-men
apocalypse is in full swing and the
latest trailer gave everyone a tease of
fan-favorite Wolverine it seems we'll be
seeing a lot more of those adamantium
claws and probably covered in blood and
guts by the sound of things I'm Simon
and this is your mutant powered news
updates Xmen apocalypse will hit cinemas
this month and the internet has been
alive with promotion we know that
Wolverine will return within the movie
although it's not known to what extent
following that Jaclyn will play the
character one more time in Wolverine
three it has now been reported that the
film has started shooting collider spoke
to x-men producer Simon Kinberg this
week who revealed that Wolverine free
was now in production he also confirmed
an earlier rumor that the film would be
released with an hour certificate it's a
very radical bold different Wolverine
that you've ever seen in any of these
other movies it takes place in the
future and as you and others have
reported it is an r-rated movie it's
violent it's kind of like a Western in
its tone it's just a very cool different
film Kinberg was also asked if Patrick
Stewart would reprise the role of
Professor X as rumored last year but
remained kg on the subject I'm not sure
what I'm allowed to say about that I
will agree with you that Patrick Stewart
was rumored to be part of the film
Wolverine 3 will be directed by james
mangold who previously helmed 2013's the
wolverine which went on to make more
than 400 million dollars worldwide at
san diego comic-con last year Jackman
hinted strongly that the film would draw
from the old man Logan liner comic books
a futuristic storyline which sees
Wolverine as the world's last remaining
mutant Wolverine 3 is set for release on
March third 2017 does this idea of a
Deadpool style gorefest with Wolverine
excite you let me know in the comments
or come find me on Twitter I'm at the j
gun or thanks for watching of all your
entertainment news keep it gamespot
Oh